Я боюсь…
На тлі третьої хвилі пандемії коронавірусу українці запекло дискутують  про щеплення та закупівлю вакцин,
критикують темпи вакцинаці та нарікають на недоступність вакцин інших виробників.
А ще - намагаються записатися в електронні черги, щоб отримати щеплення від CОVIDd-19.
Але як щодо інших інфекційних хвороб? Чи так само активно українці щеплюються?
На сайті центру громадського здоров'я ми бачимо, що рівень охоплення плановими щепленнями за 2020 рік вкрай низький.
У віці 16 років від дифтерії і правця щепилось 73% від річного плану українців, а ось у категорії "дорослі" лише 47%.
І я - одна з тих, хто складає цю негативну статистику.
Востаннє, здається, я вакцинувалась ще в школі.
Ну а форму 063, куди лікарі й вписували всі зроблені щеплення, тримала в руках, коли подавала документи на вступ в університет.
Просто тому, що без неї документи взагалі не приймали. Відтоді про планові вакцинації я й не згадувала.
Сімейна медицина - реформа, яка мала б спонукати українців зайнятись профілактикою свого здоров'я.
Що ж, я й тут створила негативну статистику, адже досі не підписала декларації з сімейним лікарем.
Це треба змінити!  Перший крок - знайти стару медичну картку і форму вакцинації.
Тату, тут така справа. Треба, щоб ти знайшов мою дитячу медичну книжку, допоможеш?
Немає питань - зробимо.
Якщо ви також не знаєте, де ваша форма вакцинації - запитайте у батьків: вони мають про неї пам’ятати.
Якщо ж картки вдома немає, зверніться до архіву вашої дитячої поліклініки.
Адже без того папірця в лікарні вас вважатимуть зовсім не вакцинованим. А не для цього ви в дитинстві відстраждали.
Моя картка таки знайшлась! Тепер з нею йду на консультацію до терапевта в приватну клініку.
Одразу вручаю свою знахідку - дитячу медичну картку та форму 063.
Вона ретро, але тут все є. Якщо будете робити зараз вакцинацію, то, звісно, ніхто не буде вписувати в цю картку.
Зроблять нову, сучасну і перенесуть всі дані звідси туди.
Коли йдеться про вакцинацію дітей, батьки виявляють неабияку послідовність:
календар щеплень не пропускають, каже лікарка.
Це, звісно, якщо батьки не належать до антивакцинувальників, про яких згадаємо згодом.
А от коли треба стежити за власним здоров'ям, ентузіазм дорослих швидко вичерпується.
Невже бояться того "комарика", який швидко і неболяче жалить в ручку?
Що може бути з дорослими, які пропускають вакцинацію?
Хворіти, неприємно хворіти. Ось нещодавно, дуже багато дорослих перехворіло на кір.
І коли це 5-7 днів лихоманки під сорок і ти з нею нічого не можеш зробити, а жарознижчуючі дають ефективність на невеличкий термін
і вона знову піднімається.  Але кожна людина, одна з тисячі, може мати енцефаліт,
і він може бути таким, який закінчиться прикованістю до ліжка…
До речі, чимало європейських країн заявили, що подолали кір, адже роками не фіксують цю небезпечну інфекційну хворобу.
Україну ж, за сплески захворюваності, назвали європейською столицею кору.
Востаннє вакцинуються від цієї хвороби у шестирічному віці.
Ще п’ять років тому рівень охоплення вакцинації від кору не доходив і до 50%,
станом на 2020 рік від кору вакцинувалось 83% від річного плану маленьких українців.
Та для колективного імунітету цього замало. Так само і з іншими хворобами.
У нас було чотири випадки в країні дифтерії, якої загалом не мало б бути.
- Це багато 4 випадки?
Чотири випадки - це багато, бо  дуже висока смертність від цієї інфекції.
І це могло б мати нехороші наслідки для всієї країни. Так само є поліомієліт, якого могло б і не бути.
Згідно із затвердженим календарем щеплень діти до 16 років мають отримати вакцини від 10 хвороб.
Всю інформацію можна знайти на сайті Центру громадського здоров'я.
Деякі щеплення, які нині є обов'язковими для дітей, в часи мого дитинства не проводились.
Нарпиклад, гепатит В. Тож лікар радить зробити і це щеплення.
Так само, як і вакцину від вірусу папіломи, яку як необов’язкову радять також зробити дітям до початку статевого життя.
А от вакцинація від дифтерії і правця є обов'язковою для дорослих.
Робити її треба щодесять років.  В приватних клініках, наприклад, від дифтерії і правця є вакцини харківського і бельгійського виробництв.
Різниця не лише в ціні. Так, бельгійська комбінована ще захистить від коклюшу, що особливо потрібно жінкам репродуктивного віку.
Тож тут уже вибір на ваш гаманець. Я ж вирішила перевірити, як діє державна медицина і щепитись безкоштовно.
Та для цього необхідно нарешті підписати декларацію з сімейним лікарем.
Знайти його можна або через рекомендацію друзів, або ж звернувшись до найближчого Центру первинної медико-санітарної допомоги.
Так я й познайомилася з уже теперішньою моєю сімейною лікаркою Наталею Шпильовою.
Зараз ми заключаємо декларацію, потім створюємо електронну карточку,
далі я вас огляну і, якщо немає протипоказів, ми вас направляємо на вакцинацію.
Протипокази від вакцинації  - це або підвищена температура, або ж загальна слабкість чи інші особливості організму, про які я вже точно б знала.
Наприкад, анафілактичний шок. Не впливає на вакцинацію і сезонність: байдуже, чи це рання весна, чи спекотне літо.
Щодо самої вакцини, то від дифтерії і правця держава закуповує індійську вакцину.
У нас все так вважається, що чим дорожча, тим краща, і Індія вважається чомусь поганою, чогось.
Ваш досвід що каже?
Мій досвід каже, що ні. Навпаки.
Я сама щеплювалась індійською вакциною, і сім'я моє це робить, ми не купуємо додаткових вакцин, лише щорічна вакцина від грипу.
І ось, нарешті, кабінет щеплень…
Будемо щеплення робити в ліве плече. Рука після вакцинації трішки поболить, таке враження, як крепатура,
при рухові руки неприємні враження. У кого сильніше, в кого слабкіше.
Якщо рука в місці уколу злегка  припухла, чи почервоніла, або якщо є невелика температура 37.5, то червону кнопку паніки не вмикаємо.
Це нормальне явище. Це не означає, що воно у вас буде, але я все одно попереджаю всіх.
Працюємо.
Працюємо… Я боюсь...
У нас там трамвайчики прекрасні ходять, дуже красиві, прекрасні, сучасні. Тому можете подивитись у вікно і розслабитись.
Це вже все? О, ви так гарно заговорили мене!
Виявляється, що комарик справді не сильно жалить…
Що ж, тепер я вакцинована від дифтерії і правця і маю свою новеньку книжку вакцинації.
Вже після процедури зустрілась з головною лікаркою Центру.
Алла Сваток розповідає, що через Covid-19 рівень вакцинації нині впав, хоча й до цього він був не надто високим.
І це попри те, що сімейні лікарі постійно обдзвонюють своїх пацієнтів та нагадують їм про вакцинацію.
Зараз з дорослими ситуація погана, але ще гірша з дітьми:
мами молоді начитуються в інтернеті багато чого і не щеплюють дітей.
Оце страшне. Діти маленькі не мають імунітету. І ми частого говоримо..
це хоч і не гарно, але, чомусь як є тваринки в хаті, ми їх щеплюємо, щоб з ними нічого не сталось.
А за дітей так не думаємо, чомусь.
Ситуацію могла б змінити соціальна реклама чи державна політика інформування, кажуть лікарі.
Про брак інформації говорять під стінами лікарні і самі пацієнти.
У свій час робив, а що, треба і зараз робити? Ну, буду знати, може, і зроблю.
Дифтерію і правець боїтесь?
Так
То чому ж не робили?
Не знаю. Чесно, халатність, можливо, часу немає.
Взагалі не робила, взагалі.
Дитині планово всі робимо, обов‘язково, а собі – ні, на жаль. Не права? треба робити.
Для дорослих – ні, не знаю. Говорив лікар, що треба. Будемо, значить, робити.
Ранок після вакцинації.
Я почуваюсь добре, просто хочу спати. Але це традиційно для кожного мого ранку.
І ніяких подразнень, почервонінь немає. Ніяких шрамів і слідів.
Щоправда, протягом дня температура таки піднялась. Слабкість і ломота в тілі мене здолали, тож цілий день я просто валялась в ліжку.
Тому моя особиста рекомендація така: вакцинуватись краще перед вихідними чи взявши на роботі вихідний.
Однак відчуття, що ти - супергерой, який доклав свою крихту до колективного імунітету, не зникало ще кілька днів. І це приємно.
За підрахунками  ВООЗ, про безпеку населення можна говорити лише тоді,
коли від смертельних інфекційних хвороб вакциновано не менше 95% людей.
А рух противників вакцинації в організації віднесли до десятка найбільших загроз для здоров’я людства.